our Romeo what happens if you are right
well just in the same way that we now
regard as a barbaric to saw off a limb
just because you have some problems with
that limb in the future I think that we
will regard jacking up your
neurotransmitters by 20 X and then
waiting a couple weeks and seeing if
you're better or worse will be regarded
as barbaric and so if we're right then
we have an entirely new and different
paradigm for intervening on mental
health we like to refer to it as pattern
suta khals where we could have a much
more precise intervention on exactly the
symptoms that you're having and it
wouldn't be you know go away for two
weeks and see what happens it'd be
real-time feedback of what is this doing
to your mental state so there's some
sort of an issue with the mental state
and then there can be an applied pattern
suitable and then an immediate feedback
loop yes to make sure that it's correct
and then what would be like a most
common pattern suitable that would be
applied to a most common mental health
issue it's the most common is a deeper
understanding of depression and anxiety
which if you look at methods to
investigate how big of a quality-of-life
impact are these conditions having
people rank something like severe
depression up there with losing a limb
so it's it's a pretty big impact in
people's lives and what would be a
pattern suitable application - oh that's
that's a complicated question because
that's what you're working on right now
okay how do you mean exactly that so it
may be be a symmetrical state like a
pattern suited goal of a symmetrical
state for someone most likely seeing the
ways in which they are currently
experiencing their own environment as
dissonant